[Musique]
je transmets pas mafiosi leur vie à
celle et mettre mes techniques
technique se déplacer
[Musique]
aulas
c'était très plaisant de gagner
aujourd'hui aussi d'obtenir le maillot
jaune
ce sera sympa de le porter ce maillot
jaune demain aujourd'hui c'était une
étape très dure avec beaucoup de vent
mais l'équipe a fait du très bon travail
avec est six coureurs dans le premier
groupe
[Musique]
oh
ya beaucoup de choses qui bougent bout à
bout d'un côté et le cndd stop comme sur
la spli difficile et moi c'est en avoir
fini j'ai pas aux grandes capacités
pulmonaires donc tu joues à cames à
force de volonté
[Musique]
la magie du quidditch c'est pouvoir
mélanger plusieurs sports pour en créer
un nouveau
et après on est sur des manipulations de
balles sur du dodge ball a condamné un
américain on est sûrs d'eux mêmes
manipulations du ballon de volée oui
j'espère cette première place qu'ils ont
occupé les trois quarts de l'année ça
fait vraiment plaisir tout le mérite en
revient aux joueurs au staff au sikkim
en un qui m'accompagne la direction qui
m'a fait confiance cette année est
vraiment fier aussi de terminer
meilleure défense de la ligue de paris
[Musique]
photo charles lima gelati coeurs
fonctionnant tous les balcons qui fout
ça me donne des idées de la compétition
approche plus plus agrandi prix à
défaire des sens donc c'est bien pour
nous c'est positif pour les enfants qui
sont pleins d'énergie donc un emprunt
c'est bien c'est toujours valorisant
d'être sur un terrain de faire partager
ce que sinon ce qui nous a permis de
gagner pas mal de titres
[Musique]
l'effet du français était là à crier
encore et encore je me suis dit il faut
que j'aille pop geste et j'ai poussé
dans les bosses s'est passé c'est juste
incroyable d'avoir gagné ici je suis
enfin sorti du salar de uyuni j'ai
rejoint la terre les cailloux s'asseoir
sur autre chose que sur du sel parce que
j'en avais marre d'avoir les fesses tout
blanc fait que de ça donc voilà c'est la
fin de cette aventure
après 140 km parcouru six jours de
solitude donc des airs
[Musique]
ce que du bonheur c'est l'aboutissement
de huit mois de travail pour eux mais
j'équipe à y sont naturellement et puis
une centaine bonne centaine de bénévoles
mais effectivement c'est du bonheur
parce que on va enfin vivre cette
journée à rambouillet tant attendu pour
les rambos littamé pour le territoire et
pour beaucoup de visiteurs nature
[Musique]
je m'attendais pas du tout à gagner pas
du tout j'y étais allé en plus tôt en
mode plutôt défi personnel je voulais
vivre aussi une expérience avec d'autres
sirènes
parce que c'est pas tous les jours que
l'on peut rencontrer des sirènes en
france
[Musique]
c'est très très rare de les avoir c'est
vrai en france parce qu'ils voyagent
déjà un fou qui se déplace et on les a
déjà eu deux trois ans et c'est vrai que
c'est très rare qui viennent et c'est
vraiment exceptionnel de les avoir en
france or je pense que mon niveau même
toute la semaine était très bon
donc
je savais que je pouvais bien joué ici
parce que j'avais je l'avais déjà fait
l'année passée j'avais gagné ici aussi
donc je me sentais bien je me sens très
confiant
[Musique]
c'est mythique
c'est une des courses une des quatre
cinq courses mythiques en france puis en
l1 du coin vous versez y ont cours en
pleine campagne mais c'est pas un trade
c'est difficile mais à l'arrivée on est
toujours satisfait
[Musique]
c'est énormément de joueurs voilà ça
fait ça fait 18 ans que je suis pro j'ai
gagné deux fois j'aurais dû gagner plus
souvent comme je le dis souvent fait de
gagner chez vous c'est génial j'ai joué
un peu l'impression de faire partie du
paysage golfique français
[Musique]
ça me plaît parce que voilà j'ai des
anecdotes aussi dans mon passé qui m'ont
permis de rencontrer des champions je je
m'en souviens ça m'a marqué je m'en suis
servi